so this is the question
okay which to be honest it's not that
hard but because we we made it so seldom
we're used to e being down the bottom
here that's why you kind of scratch your
head over it a little bit okay
so here are your two options here are
your two options you can remember you
can choose to remember that if you can
remember
if you have any constant raised to the
power of x any constant you like okay
then the derivative is a to the x log a
and when you have a being equal to e
that's the special case where you get e
to the x log e and log n is just
one okay so that's why it disappears
you can choose to remember this in which
case if you do
you come over here
and you say well this is
chain rule isn't it because there's a 5x
up there okay so what's the derivative
of 5x
5
and then you do the outside function
which is a constant raise to something
that's the scenario here isn't it okay
so you're going to get uh what are you
going to get 2 to the 5x times log 2 and
there's your answer ok so obviously
that's kind of your ideal because it's
just one line there's nothing else to it
okay but you have to remember this
now your alternative is to say look i
can we're used to doing these with base
e so i'm going to make it basic even
though it's not right now okay so how do
you change it you need to remember
something else
namely this
okay
there's an identity for you um in some
ways you know this is no better than the
previous one because you either have to
remember this or you remember that okay
but this is this is useful anyway
suppose you can't remember that this is
true
suppose you don't remember what e to the
log x is okay so i'm just going to give
it a name i'm going to call it k we want
to find out what k is
now when you've got this kind of
equation an exponential equation it
helps to rewrite it okay in um
in in log form and then we can see some
stands out of it so let's do it with
this because everyone knows that this is
true this is an exponential equation so
how would you rewrite that equation
yeah
as a log equation
how would you translate it it's a log
equation of the corresponds to this
base
log base 2 of 32 is 5 right so you look
at that and you think okay this base
turns into this base right
what used to be the subject here becomes
inside the log and then your power goes
over here and do the same thing over
here
log base what should the base be
it should be the same base that i have
here right
okay
where did this 32 k come from it came
from the other side so this should be
k
right
and then the power up here moves over to
the right hand side so this is and i'll
write it out in proper long form log
base e of x
yeah oh hold on okay so that tells you
that k and x
are equal right which it gives you back
where we started
okay is that all right
now how do i use that for this okay well
i can say the derivative then of 2 to
the 5x
i'm going to get rid of that 2.
i'm going to replace it with if i want 2
over here
then where should i replace the other
two
up where x is right
like so okay so i'm going to replace
that 2
with
e to the power of log 2. that's my
that's 2 right there okay
and that's all to the power of 5
okay i suppose you could do this if you
like but it ends up being the same
because of index
okay now can you differentiate this guy
the answer is yes you can okay uh it's
chain rule again right it's e to the
power of sub function okay let's
rehearse this what's the chain rule for
either power of a function
you do the inside it gives you f dash
and then you do the outside which is e
to the which nothing happens to it right
so you get this back
so let's just give that a go over here
what's f dash well f is
log 2 times 5 times x
log 2 is a constant 5 is a constant this
is just a linear function up here so its
derivative is 5 log 2. is that ok that's
my f dash
then i've got e to the power of
the function e to the power of log 2
times
5 x right but
i don't need to write it like that
anymore i only wrote it like that so i
could differentiate i know a much
simpler way to write that namely 2 to
the 5x which is exactly what you got
before
okay
so either of these ways to find
clearly this is faster okay however it's
in your interest to remember
let's put it back to x's shall we
it's in your interest to remember this
this is a super useful identity in lots
of places and this is one of the reasons
why okay
it is a bit of a convoluted way to get
there but you'll get it and it works
just fine